il ya 10 ans l' affaire des bébés
congelés l'un des faits divers les plus
marquants des années 2000 caroline devos
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste à la
nouvelle république à tours vous avez
couvert la faire à l'époque sept ans
vous étiez en france et en corée alors
le 16 octobre 2006 la tourangelle
véronique courjault a avoué le meurtre
de trois nouveau nés deux seront
retrouvés dans le congélateur du
logement familial à séoul en corée du
sud
quand vous découvrez les faits en
juillet 2006 est ce que vous vous dites
d'ampli c'est une affaire hors norme
oui je crois que immédiatement on a
senti que c'était une affaire
exceptionnelle
d'abord parce qu'il ya eu une sorte de
mystère pendant plusieurs semaines
d'un côté il y avait les enquêteurs
coréen qui accusait les époux courjault
d'être les parents des deux bébés
retrouvés morts à séoul mais puis de
l'otan en touraine ici il y avait un
genre unique et jean louis courjault qui
eux crier leur innocence et disait qu'il
n'avait rien à voir dans cette affaire
est immédiatement cette affaire a fait
énormément de bruit beaucoup de
reporters français et coréens sont venus
à tour pour pour faire leurs reportages
sur cette affaire
et évidemment la nature des faits aussi
le fait que ce soit un infanticide
le potentiel est dans mes moments de
bruit on a tout de suite su que c'était
une affaire qui allait faire beaucoup de
bruit alors vous l'avez dit un caroline
véronique courjault passe aux aveux le
16 octobre des aveux tardifs 1 pendant
plusieurs mois elle a nié avoir accouché
de ses bébés les avoir tués pourtant il
y avait des preuves accablantes
il y avait des preuves en corée du sud
puisque les enquêteurs correa avait mené
des expertises adn et avait déterminé
que selon véronique et jean louis
courjault était bien les parents des
deux bébés qui avaient été retrouvés
dans le congélateur de la ville mais
véronique courjault et jean louis
courjault disait que que les enquêteurs
s'étaient trompés on a même parlé d'un
complot éventuellement et il a fallu
donc que des semaines pour que la
justice coréenne transmette à la justice
française l'épreuve et que les
expertises adn soir fait ici en france
par hallab oratoire français et ce jour
là donc le 16 octobre 2006 ce
laboratoire a livré les résultats de
cette expertise et a confirmé ce
qu'avaient dit les enquêteurs coréen
c'est à dire que les roenick et jean
louis courjault était bien les parents
de ces bébés alors vous avez suivi le
procès de véronique courjault en juin
au-delà des faits qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ce procès je pense notamment
l'aspect psychologique
il ya effectivement je crois que c'est
là où cette affaire est vraiment
importante est exceptionnel c'est sur le
fait qu'on ait cherché vraiment dans la
psychologie de véronique courjault ce
qui a pu permettre d'arriver à cette
situation incroyable parce qu'en plus la
plupart des affaires d'infanticide
concernent des fans très jeunes ou de
milieux très défavorisés
et là ce n'était pas le cas c'était une
femme ordinaire comme l'eau comme moi
comme n'importe quelle autre femme
elle avait déjà des enfants donc c'est
vrai qu'on avait énormément de mal à
comprendre
il ya eu à l'occasion de cette affaire
un débat autour du déni de grossesse
et c'est vrai que le grand public a
découvert cette notion de déni de
grossesse
à cette occasion je crois qu'on a jeté
un regard différent sur les mères
infanticides
à partir de cette affaire merci caroline
devos est venu sur notre plateau